the world has the way of changing and we  change too i know  there are moments that separate us  but we always come back together  we heard y'all needed a little love out  here  y'all ever thought about the wild  missions we've been on we've taken out  planes  trains tanks  [Music]  and now we got cars flying in the air  who is he  there's a long time though little  brother  you always say never turn your back on  family  but you turned your back on me  now your little family is in my world  are you ready he's got his own private  [Music]  so how do you all want to play this fast  we going oh  okay this is a bad time to mention this  but i don't drive  brother against brother this should be  interesting  but could you kill him  crank it all the way up get back with  the soldiers  now  and now you spend the rest of yours  living in mine  [Music]  duct tape you acting like we on our way  to home depot  i don't wanna die